let's get to Tom Waddell the former
Chicago Bear wide receiver and a co-host
of Waddell and Sylvie 2 to 6 on ESPN
1000 in Chicago good morning Tom how are
you I'm doing well Dan how are you guys
hope everyone is safe and healthy if I
said you could watch one of these the
Super Bowl or the first four days of
March Madness what would you take Super
Bowl I'm a football cap no no I like
basketball don't get me wrong but you
know footballs in my blood all right
what did you want the Bears to do before
they brought in Nick Foles what did you
want them to do this season interesting
I wanted them to upgrade a lot of spots
on their offense they were pretty
pitiful in a lot of areas they were 29th
and yards per game they were 29th and
points per game they didn't run the
football I wanted them to secure their
offensive line I wanted to get them to
make a significant upgrade at tight end
but certainly it all circles back to the
quarterback and I wanted them to find
somebody that can for the defense as
well as elite as this one is helped lead
them to the promised land and it was a
familiarity with Nick Foles was with
Matt naggy and the rest of the new
coaches that he's he's put together I
think that obviously familiarity was was
high on their list with Nick you like
this move I do I think they're up great
I think it's an upgrade look I'm not
suggesting that Nick Foles is going to
be the reincarnation of you know Aaron
Rodgers five six years ago but Nick
holds is it dan I think Nick Foles is a
professional quarterback especially in
this offense that he knows like the back
of his hand he knows where the football
is supposed to go now will it always get
there maybe not but he understands the
offense and he understands how to read
defenses and he understands how to go
through his progressions and would you
know it sounds awful but I'm not so sure
that that Mitch was really in the same
category I don't know that he possesses
all of that in comparison and neck but
Nick's a veteran and as I said has
experience in this offense so what's
Mitchell true Biscay future in Chicago I
may be in the minority but I don't think
it's I don't think it's a very
stable 1 dan I don't think you give up a
fourth-round pick and 21 million dollars
guaranteed when a you don't have a ton
of draft currency and B you have some
tight salary cap situations so to give
up what they gave up for Nick Foles I
may be crazy but I don't think you give
up 1/4 K him 21 million guaranteed and
bring him to Chicago and sit him behind
a young quarterback who has struggled in
a quarterback that I don't believe the
coach believes in that seems to be
foolish to me how did they with on true
Biscay and and not only with they moved
up to whiff on him and moved up and
decided to pass on Watson in mahomes
it's the question that has left the kind
of Bayer fans including myself
pacing my house at this time banging my
head against walls and one that I I
really can't I can't come to a solid
conclusion look I get that you could
have missed on mahomes obviously the
Kansas City Chiefs Denton and they were
they were sold from day one but how do
you miss on deshaun Watson who was the
best player in the country on the
biggest stage under the brightest lights
against virtually a professional defense
that he faced in Alabama and he excelled
the way he did I don't know I mean
listen I prefaced everything I've said
over the course of the last three years
is I don't want to feel like I'm bashing
Mitch because I know Mitch is a
wonderful kid who was a hard worker and
he's a great teammate but he hasn't been
a very good quarterback and we're in the
business of winning game I don't know
Danny I they must have fallen in love
with what they saw in his 13 game career
in in North Carolina and and it just
it's it it's an answer that I can't find
a good one or a question I can't find a
good answer for but you've been around
these GM's and these coaches they love
the unknown they love the potential for
something and I've always said I don't
care about a pro day I don't care about
the combine put on the tape that's why
I'm example we're discounting Teddy
Bridgewater oh you had a horrible Pro
dick put on the tape and tell me how
tough he is
and the same with deshaun Watson I think
that the Bears probably looked at the
Shawn Watson and goes okay well we know
that's his ceiling probably and he did
pretty well but look at this guy over
here you know he's only played 13 games
like this is what we get this how we get
into trouble with maybe Baker Mayfield
with Dwayne Haskins
it's these one-year wonders where we go
look at that and then you go oh my god I
mean even Joe burrow the previous year
was pedestrian like and then he had the
unbelievable one season so I think it's
these GM's they talked themselves in and
out of things and I think that's what
the Bears did yeah I agree with you and
I think a lot there some people in town
that had given Ryan a ton of credit for
his conviction well I'd trade conviction
for confidence every day of the week so
look I think if you're gonna go with a
guy who only had one year in college at
least go with a guy that won the Heisman
Trophy you know what I'm saying I mean
like I can understand Cuyler Murray you
pick Tyler Murray because the one season
that he did play he was outstanding I
get it for some of these guys and again
I I'm gonna have to go to confession
because I feel awful all the time by
saying bad things about men but but look
he you know he had a nice year with with
North Carolina in the one year that he
played I just don't know how you fall in
love with that and you move up and give
up draft currency to making the second
overall pick when you had to Shawn
Watson and him sitting there I just mean
it I'm baffled former Bears wide
receiver Tom Arnold joining us on the
program if I gave you the Buccaneers or
the Bears more wins this year Wow I
actually think the Bucks are going to be
a wild-card team and I think the Bears
are also going to be a wild-card team so
now I have to decide which one has the
better record I'm going to suggest to
you that the Chicago Bears will have the
lesser record I like what Tampa's done
you know and my first thought was why
because that's not common was going back
to New England because thought it was
the best decision for both but look
everyone's talking about Mike
my Gammons is a hell of a player Chris
God one's a hell of a receiver as well I
mean you've got company the one thing
I'm concerned about with Tampa's is they
gave up 45 sacks last year because they
also I think threw the football more
than anyone else and I don't think
you'll have the same situation with Tom
he'll get the ball out quickly I think
it was a defensive played significantly
better in the second half of the season
than they did in the first half and I
think they were what seven and nine and
a lot of those those those losses were
by a smaller margin and I think you
remove some of the mistakes with
turnovers the Jameis was guilty of and I
think you've got a chance there so yeah
Carolina's going to be rebuilding some
the Falcons are a roller coaster that
sank to the the obviously the strength
of that division but I'm gonna go out on
a limb and say that the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers when nine or ten games this
year yeah I think they I thought they
were gonna be a playoff team even if
they didn't get Brady if you put Teddy
Bridgewater in there because look at all
the turnovers you know that that that's
killed that team and you get somebody
who can take care of the football you
got a good defense and you can make some
plays with those wide receivers you got
two good tight ends I just I thought
that they were on the verge of being a
playoff Tim I agree with you and and
sometimes the best route is and I'm sure
Bruce Arians has said this to several of
his quarterbacks over the course of time
and Bruce has got what a wonderful
resume is hey listen you don't have to
win this game for us kid but don't be
the reason why we lose and if you go
back Jameis has got a ton of talent but
30 interceptions
six or seven fumbles and you could see
some of this
I mean you I'm not suggesting that I'm a
football prophet but when he came out of
Florida State some of the same decisions
the the decision making on the field I
won't even talk about the off the field
stuff but the on the field decisions
were questionable at times and there was
a high number of interceptions even at
Florida State and you know it's not a
huge surprise that some of those issues
have manifests themselves here at the
NFL level great to talk to you Tom tell
Sylvie we settle oh we appreciate your
time as always
you got it thank you dan B well that's
Tom Waddell the former bear co-host of
Waddell and Sylvie afternoon Drive and
ESPN 1000 in Chicago